pierre bonjour les réactions évidemment
s'enchaînent depuis ce matin réaction de
Berlin Londres Paris Rome mais aussi
Bruxelles donc effectivement on a eu
Joseph Borel le chef de la diplomatie
européenne qui se dit profondément
choqué par ses frappes contre le coeur
même de l'Ukraine qui estime que de tels
actes n'ont pas leur place au 21e siècle
qui annonce que de nouvelles aides
militaires sont en route pour l'Ukraine
on des aid militaires dont on n'a pas le
détail mais évidemment vous l'avez
rappelé volody mirzielens qui a demandé
à Emmanuel Macron et olafchalt ce matin
des renforcements de sa défense aérienne
se pourrait être ce genre de matériel
vers lequel les Européens pourraient
s'orienter maintenant la France a promis
18 nouveaux canons Césars des vendredis
dernier des canons qui devaient partir
pour le Danemark qui iront probablement
donc vers l'Ukraine l'Allemagne qui a
annoncé après cet entretien avec entre
la Scholl c'est volo diverselenski la
convocation de cette réunion du G7 les
inquiétudes des Européens sont aussi
attisés par le fait que la Biélorussie
déclare vouloir une force déclare la
création d'une force conjointe
Russo biélorus en parlant d'attaque
contre le territoire biélorus la
Moldavie qui signale le 3 missiles tirés
par des navires russes de la mer Noire
ont survolé son territoire et convoque
donc l'ambassadeur russe qui chinet ce
matin et il y a aussi le la le ministère
polonais les affaires étrangères qui
fait écho assez préoccupations en
parlant d'un acte de barbarie et d'un
crime de guerre contre l'Ukraine on sent
les Européens mobilisés à nouveau dans
leur unité depuis leur sommet de Prague
reste à voir maintenant quels seront
effectivement les soutiens tangibles
qu'ils apporteront au-delà de ce qui
pourrait être décidé politiquement au
sein du G7 ce mardi merci beaucoup
pierre Bénazet